[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello listening friends you want to hear
an amazing fact in the early 1800s
communications in North America were
carried by foot horse or train across
the country depending on the weather and
road conditions it could take weeks or
months to get a message from
coast-to-coast
but then in 1832 Samuel FB Morse an
accomplished American painter while
visiting France was inspired about an
idea he heard of sending messages
electronically through a wire more spent
the next 12 years perfecting a working
Telegraph instrument during the same
period he also composed a digital
alphabet better known as Morse code a
set of short and long dot and dash
sounds that could represent different
letters and numbers and telegraph
messages Morse eventually convinced
Congress to finance a Washington to
Baltimore telegraph line on May 24 1844
and a demonstration witnessed by the
members of Congress he inaugurated the
world's first commercial Telegraph Morse
relayed the message what hath God
wrought the quote taken from numbers 23
23 was very fitting considering how the
first electronic message or email would
transform the future of global
communications just a decade after the
first line opened more than 20 thousand
miles of telegraph cable crisscross the
country the rapid communication help
provide greatly to empower American
expansion today over two hundred and
five billion email messages are sent
each day as in the days of Samuel Morse
the Bible is still the most often quoted
book in
females stay with his friends we're
going to learn more on this edition of
Bible answers live you're listening to
Bible answers live honest answers to
your Bible questions this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
you can even watch and listen and that
would be the amazing facts face book
page or the Doug Batchelor face book
page and send us our callin with your
Bible questions we've got some Bibles at
our fingertips here we'll do our best to
search the word and find the answers one
more time 804 6 3 7 2 97 with your Bible
questions my name is Doug Batchelor my
name is John Ross good evening friends
and as we always do let's start the
program with the word of Prayer dear
father we thank you that we have this
time to open up your word and study the
most important book that has to do with
the most important subject that anyone
could study that of eternal life and we
do pray for your blessing as we search
the Scriptures together in Jesus name
Amen
amen pastor day you open the program by
talking about well something that we
probably take for granted just the
simplicity of picking up your phone or
sending a text message or an email and
immediately being able to communicate
with somebody around the world and ask
just you know people are so used to that
and of course think of all the emails
that have been sent back and forth it
seems like businesses run on email
communication and yet you mentioned that
even today when it comes to emails the
most oft quoted
is the Bible that was kind of
interesting surprising to me but it's
true
yeah people are always sending verses to
share their and they're quoting from the
Bible and everything from you know God
is love or whatever there happened their
favorite verses both Christians and even
secular people might be quoting things
like turn the other cheek or go the
Second Mile or cast the first stone
all the handwriting's on the wall yeah
exactly by the skin of my teeth at my
wit's end there's a lot of there's a lot
of quotes in the Bible I didn't know
we're biblical until I read the Bible
it's fascinating to me the speed of
communication right now that you know
even as we're doing this were you and I
we've had phone calls from Australia and
Africa all over the world live and you
just think about what Samuel Morse would
have thought of that mm-hmm and you know
when he first developed his telegraph
system eventually it followed the train
tracks across the country and it would
connect you know what used to take days
to get a message Pony Express I think
could do it in like five days from where
was it st. Louis the Sacramento where we
are and then it was almost instantaneous
with the doesn't it that you ever heard
anybody do Morse code yes when I was
young at this pretty popular they still
learn Morse code for ham radio operation
yeah exactly
yeah but now you know the Bible tells us
that in the last days one of the signs
of the end is that knowledge would
increase and you can read about that in
Daniel chapter 12 it says but you Daniel
this is verse 4 shut up the words and
seal the book until the time of the end
many will run to and fro and knowledge
will increase you know I remember when
you'd send an email message and you had
a phone modem and it would it would dial
in and then it would connect and it was
so slow but we were thrilled we thought
this is great and now if you don't have
fiber-optic you think it's a stone-age
well you know one of the signs of the
end is the increase in knowledge and it
is increasing in this generation
exponentially the Bible prophecy said
that would happen and there are a lot
more amazing secrets in the Bible
you might be surprised to learn and we
have a free offer that talks about how
you could better understand this book
and the prophecies of the Bible this
free offer that we have is part of our
amazing fact study guide series and pass
today this is been around for a number
of years but we get people calling us
and contacting us literally around the
world telling us how they've been
blessed by this Bible study series it
looks at some of the most important
Bible truths and this is the first
lesson in the series of these study
guides it's called is there anything
left you can trust that's about the
Bible I think you'll find it just it's
filled with great interesting
fascinating facts about the Bible how do
you study the Bible with it the Bible
come from it's free all you're left to
do is call our resource phone line
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and as for the
study guide called is there anything
left you can trust and why are you
talking to the operator on the phone you
might also mention you're interested in
the free Bible study course that amazing
facts office and they'll be able to sign
you up at three we'll be sending you the
next in the series of these of these
lessons and I think you'll be blessed so
yeah and just ask for is there anything
left you can trust the number is 883
five six seven four seven all right we
got our first caller with a Chris
listing in Florida Chris welcome to the
program claim to again pastors good
evening
evening I have a quick question about
from Luke Luke 7 verse 35 alright I can
read that matter of fact I probably
ought to read verse 34 just to give
context yeah some of the disciples of
John the Baptist were saying look you
know John the Baptist he was fasting he
didn't drink wine and you said he has a
demon the Son of man came eating and
drinking you say a glutton and a
wine-bibber a friend of tax collectors
and sinners notice was Jesus speaking he
said but wisdom is justified by all of
her children are you wondering what that
means wisdom is justified by all of her
children yes yes correct and by the way
you also find that verse in Matthew 11
19 it's almost word-for-word the same
Christ is just saying there that the
wise people will understand these things
that they're gonna understand the
distinction between the Ministry of John
the Baptist's and the Ministry of Jesus
if people do not want to know because
they're prejudiced against the Ministry
of Jesus they're not going to understand
but people that have the Spirit of God
and one of the gifts of God's Spirit is
wisdom if they're children of God they
will understand what is meant by that I
think another way of looking at that is
you've heard the saying you'll know a
tree a tree by its fruit so likewise
you'll know a teacher by his students
and if you looked at what the disciples
did and their preaching and they
teaching in their lives it was a
testimony to the teachings they received
from Jesus so Jesus says wisdom is
justified by her children you'll see the
results of my teaching that's a good
point the fruit of them will be in their
lives and thank you Pastor said just one
more a quick question the Geneva Bible
you know the same reformation Bible yes
how much different is it some other
Bibles and what is I have a copy of
Geneva Bible it's a great historic Bible
it uses some older archaic English of
course the message is the same it was
the Bible many of the Protestants read
one of the first English Bibles but it
can be difficult reading I think I've
got a copy too matter of fact I had
probably have a copy on my computer but
hey thank you very much Chris we
appreciate your call you know we do have
a book called the ultimate resource
talks about the Bible and gives you more
information about where the Bible came
from and different translations we'll
send it to you for free if you call 808
three five six seven four seven and just
ask for the book called the ultimate
resource annex Qualys daniel is
listening in Michigan Daniel welcome to
the program hello pastor Pastor John
yeah and your question tonight yes I had
a question about Isaiah chapter 24 which
is supposed to show you know the earth
is empty and desolate during the 1,000
years you know except for the devil and
his angels which are left on the earth
but I refuse I'd like to read on in
verse 6 so chapter before it says the
inhabitants of the earth are burned and
few
men are left and verse seven says all
the merry hearted sigh and verse nine it
says they shall not drink wine with a
song strong drink is bitter to those who
drink it and verse 10 says every house
is shut up and no when they go in verse
11 a cry for wine in the streets and all
joy is darkened and verse 13 says when
it shall be thus in the midst of the
land among the people and then verse 14
and age they shall lift up their voice
and sing and they shall cry aloud let
the sea so I'm just kind of confused
maybe I'm reading it wrong or maybe I'm
missing something here but it sounds
like there's still people on the earth
most of chapter 24 in Isaiah is talking
about what would happen Isaiah also
foretold the destruction of Jerusalem
under the Babylonians and what you just
read there is a perfect description of
that there's also a period of time when
the earth is completely desolate have
you read in jeremiah chapter 4 like 23
what you're reading in Isaiah here he's
making a prophecy Isaiah lived before
the Babylonian destruction Jeremiah
lived during it but if you look in and I
think that what happened to Jerusalem
during the Babylonian destruction they
burnt the city they burnt the temple
they burnt the walls was an allegory of
what will also happen in the last days
but if you look in Jeremiah chapter 423
it says I beheld the earth and indeed it
was without form and void and the
heavens and they had no light I beheld
the mountains and they trembled and all
the hills moved back and forth I beheld
indeed there was no man and all the
birds of heaven were fled I beheld
indeed and the fruitful place was a
wilderness and all the cities were
broken down at the presence of the Lord
and by his fierce anger so that to me I
think is a pretty clear scripture that
there's no man Isaiah where is the verse
where Isaiah says the earth is turned
upside down it's utterly emptied and he
also says that there's the the slain of
the Lord cover the earth and there's no
one to bury or lament them no one to
bury Alimentum there are several verses
that the
scribe a time when the earth is
basically vacated but you know we have a
lesson Daniel it's a good question we
have a lesson we'd be happy to send you
that has that verse the verses we gave
you and many others on the subject of
the millennium did you find one of those
pastor awesome and it's actually several
of them Isaiah chapter 26 verse 21 it
says for behold the Lord comes out of
his place to punish the inhabitants of
the earth for their iniquity the earth
will also disclose her blood and will no
more cover a slain so you have these
different sort of inter woven in
Isaiah's prophecy concerning judgment
coming upon Jerusalem by the Babylonians
they're also pictures or at least
threads referring to a future time of
judgment that occurs at the second
coming of Christ so you got to kind of
take what Isaiah says and put that
together with some of the other
prophecies in Jeremiah and of course if
you're going to the New Testament then
you see how these different verses
connect together
the lesson on the Millennium we should
send Daniel yes it's called a thousand
years of peace and we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and as for the study guide called
a thousand years of peace we want to
know God's plan for our world and
solutions for your life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
calm or by calling 858 7275 we have
Jerry listening in Oregon Jerry welcome
to the program good evening pastors
pastor the poor get started I'd like to
mention you you Rhoda you you have a
video called as hell and a place of
eternal torment you told a story where
you had a debate with them with a radial
pastor do I mention his name now
deceased well if you want pardon me you
don't need to but you can if you want to
and what's the question about the debate
well you mentioned they had a bit debate
with this man and he was the proponent
of the traditional view
but I would like to mention I listen to
him about three years before his death
and he has changed his position
completely on that he's now agreed with
you you're right he had you're right he
did can change his position my
experience took place 2530 years ago
because he's been on the radio or he was
on the radio for forty years or more so
you're right he did change his position
I I got that impression people called in
and asked him why he had but my question
almost I just thought you'd like to know
that but my question pertains to first
Corinthians 15 25 through 28 in a
concerns eternity do you want to read
that or shall I read that I can read it
first Corinthians 15 verse 25 for he
must reign until he has put all enemies
under his feet the last enemy that will
be destroyed is death for he has put all
things under his feet but when he says
all things are put under him it is
evident that he who put all things under
him is accepted now when all things are
made subject to him then the son himself
will also be subject to him who put all
things under him that God may be all in
all and your question on that
well yeah it's certainly saying that
Jesus at the end time will be under God
so how could he be co-equal with him you
can have one party submit to another
party and still have equality in value
now I have always believed that there
seems to be a sequence of authority
given in the Bible between the father
son and spirit so you and I probably
agree that there's a distinction of
roles the father is Jesus says you know
God so loved the world God the Father so
loved the world he gave the Sun so the
father's doing the giving the Bible says
God the Father created all things
through Christ the son yet the Bible
says in the beginning God made the
heaven and the earth
so the son must still be God so do you
believe that Jesus is God I'm sorry did
you say do I believe Jesus is God is
that your question yeah we have a
report-- connection on this and I think
it's a very confusing topic I can make
points one way or the other inside
many Bible texts to support it well I
would agree that the Bible says God is a
big subject in in many ways his ways are
higher than our ways but I think it's
pretty clearly revealed in the Bible
when you look at some of the primary
definitions of God that Jesus has the
characteristics I put you on hold just
because we're getting static - Jesus
fills the definitions the Bible says God
is our Savior so as Jesus is our Savior
the Bible says only God knows the
thoughts of men's hearts yet jesus knew
the thoughts of men's hearts the Bible
tells us we should only worship God but
we're told we can worship Jesus and God
created all things Bible says Jesus
created all things so when you start
going through the different definitions
of God Jesus fits them all now I don't
know if you've read the book that we
have on the subject of the Trinity but
we'll be happy to send you that book
it's one God or three questions on the
Trinity and all you'll have to do is
call our resource line that's eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven I'm looking at the book right here
on my computer it's called
the Trinity just ask for the book on the
Trinity we will be happy to send it out
to anyone who calls and asks next what
we have is Connie listening in our Eagan
Connie welcome to the program hi pastor
Darren customers I'm sitting here with
my girlfriend Susie and she has a
question
oh hi Susie in 1st Peter 4 and it's 18
through 20 but basically in verse 19 is
some clarification would be really nice
because I'd like to know if Jesus went
and preached to the spirits in the
prisons are we talking about what
spirits and what is the prison and why
is he preaching to them that's so that's
my question alright then this is a verse
that has confused some people let's
start with verse 18 and this is first
Peter chapter 3 verse 18 for christ also
suffered once for sins the just for the
unjust that he might bring us to God
being put to death in the flesh but made
alive in the spirit now the emphasis
here is
the spirit that makes alive that's the
subject of this paragraph by whom
through the spirit he Jesus went and
preached to the spirits spirits small s
there means people in prison those who
are imprisoned by sin who formerly were
disobedient when once the divine
long-suffering waited in the days of
Noah now let's pause right here and
saying the spirit preached to people who
are imprisoned by sin they were
disobedient in the days of Noah if you
pause and you go to Genesis chapter 6
verse 3 it talks about where God says my
spirit will not always strive with man
yet his days I think it's Genesis 6
Genesis 6:3 and when we read the whole
verse it says the Lord said my spirit
shall not always strive with man for his
indeed flesh yet his days shall be a
hundred and twenty years okay so it's
talking about people that live back in
the days of Noah while the ark was being
prepared in which few that is eight
souls were saved by water it's not
saying that Jesus died and he went to
hell somewhere and he started preaching
to people who were in prison because the
Bible says ye after man dies and then
there's judgment it's appointed unto man
once to die and after this the judgment
we don't get to hear the gospel again
after we're dead
that goes in the face of everything else
in the Bible it's describing what
happened back and by the way you read on
in that verse he starts talking about
baptism and he's saying the whole world
was baptized back in the days of Noah
that Noah and his family were saved
through water similar to how we are
saved through baptism and filled with
the spirit so the emphasis is Christ was
anointed he was filled with the Spirit
is baptism and it was the same spirit
that brought him back to life and that
same spirit gives us a new life I hope
that helps does that make sense yes
thank you so much
alright thanks appreciate your question
next caller that we have is Lois
listening from San Diego Louie welcome
to the program good evening pastors I
pray for your evening and I appreciate
this show I have a quick question and
interestingly about the Trinity or the
Godhead as well I do believe
that the Godhead each one each member is
God so that's not a question in my mind
the interesting question is I recently
had a thought of praying to the Holy
Spirit seeing Holy Spirit come and fill
me well I just recently had a
conversation with the pastor he said
well we should be praying to God and not
the Holy Spirit and not even to Jesus
that the example that we should be doing
is trains God or the Holy Spirit and
praying to God that the Holy Spirit
would fill us with the presence of
Christ and the father in our hearts so
I'm kind of interested to know is that
not appropriate to pray to the Holy
Spirit or to Jesus and that we should
only trade directly first to the father
you know I don't think that God faults
anybody if they were to you know extend
a prayer to the Holy Spirit God doesn't
really want us to pray to angels but we
know there are angels that are helping
answer God's prayer but nowhere in the
Bible are we told to pray to our angels
we really go to God the Father in
Christ's name and we pray in the spirit
there's one example I can think of where
someone prayed to Jesus and that's when
Stephen was being stoned he said Lord
Jesus receive my spirit and the end of
the Bible says even so come Lord Jesus
but most prayers are dressed to the
Father Pastor Ross you may know a place
in the Bible where there may be a place
where someone prays to the spirit I
can't think of any offhand hmm yeah I
don't think of a direct prayer where
someone's addressing the Holy Spirit but
there's examples where you're asking for
the Holy Spirit and Jesus says ask and
you will be given the gift of the Holy
Spirit so but you ask the Father in the
name of Jesus that's the pattern that we
see in the Bible I you know I hope that
helps a little bit now we do have a book
that talks about life in the spirit and
we'll be happy to send you a copy of
that Lois if you call the resource
number the number is 883 five six seven
four seven and again as for the
called a life in the spirit take it back
the book that he would especially enjoy
the Holy Spirit the need okay the Holy
Spirit the need is the name of the book
coming out of the same book we just
changed you know it's a it's a book okay
again eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven you can ask for the new
book called the Holy Spirit the need we
have Christian listening in Manhattan
New York Christian welcome to the
program
yeah good evening thank you for taking
my call I just have a question here that
in Romans 15 24 and 28 Paul talks about
going to Rome on his way to Spain is
there any evidence that Paul ever made
it to Spain you know that's a great
question Paul certainly have the desire
to go to Spain yeah if you go to Spain I
was there last year with my wife maybe
it was even this year time flies they
believe very much he came there there's
not a lot of tangible evidence but Paul
went some places that you know no
letters may have survived that he wrote
from these places or to these places
it's entirely possible that after he was
released his first imprisonment under
Nero he was ultimately released he
indicated he wanted to go to Spain it's
not that far from Rome to take a boat
across the Mediterranean to Spain he may
have gone and done some ministry there
and come back again we don't know all we
can do and I look at the Bible
commentaries they can say he may have it
wouldn't have been a long trip because
he never references it again but we
don't know it's it's hard for us to to
know that for sure hey thank you very
much Christian I hope that helps a
little bit well pastor Doug I'm looking
at the at the clock when we coming up on
a break here in just a few minutes don't
want to start up on another question and
didn't cut them off halfway through the
break you know we always like to remind
people well at this point that there's
so much more material that they can
listen to on the amazing facts website
if you just type in I was just in a car
with a friend and he said what's amazing
facts is to type it in you found it
right away typed in amazing facts or
just type in amazing facts ministry and
you'll see that we have videos YouTube
channels Facebook channels archived
programs like this
we've had 20 years of programs like this
no pastor don't let me just quickly add
also that we do have an app it's the
amazing facts all right a person can
download on their phone and you can get
videos our even archived or Bible
answers live it's all there so you just
look at it look it up it's just amazing
facts app in the App Store
amen a lot of information there and and
then link these things to your friends
now we do still have some lines open so
if you want to give us a call with your
Bible question the best half of the
program is about to happen and we've got
some brief station identification that
number is eight hundred four six three
seven two nine seven give us a call with
your questions stay tuned Bible answers
live will return in a moment
[Music]
did you know that Noah was present to
the birth of Abraham okay maybe he
wasn't in the room but he was alive and
probably telling stories about his
floating zoo from the creation of the
world to the last day events of
Revelation Bible history calm is a free
resource where you can explore major
Bible events and characters enhance your
knowledge of the Bible and draw closer
to God's Word go deeper visit Bible
History com if you enjoy hearing solid
biblical answers on Bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
538 7275 for life changing Christian
resources visit AF bookstore com find
out what the critics are raving about
top scholars and theologians from around
the country come together to reveal the
hidden history of the book of Revelation
with powerful reenactments and
incredible visual effects this 95 minute
masterpiece brings to life the book of
Revelation like never before revelation
is no longer a mystery get your copy
today visit iTunes or AF bookstore calm
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923 off we've got
Darrell listening in Phoenix Arizona
Darrell welcome to the program hello
pastor bachelor and pastor Ross I
appreciate you guys thank you just I had
a question well thank you I just had a
question as to graven images and whether
or not a cross is a graven image good
question
you know the Bible does not have a
command against making an image people
often read that they say thou shalt not
make an image of anything and a heaven
above the earth beneath the water under
the earth may stop so you shouldn't make
any image it's a sin and there's some
churches that will come around knock on
your door two by two and if you've got a
painting on the wall of one of your kids
or a flower they say it's an image and
technically it is Bible says do not make
images and bow down to them and serve
them because God told the children of
Israel to actually have images of
pomegranates and figs in the temple they
had angels engraved on the walls matter
of fact there were two images of angels
on the ark
it wasn't the idea of making an image
they were not to make something and bow
down to it now if a person has a cross
on a church that doesn't mean that it's
idolatry but I've been to crosses before
it's sacred shrines where it's a big
concrete cross or whatever it is or gold
and people go up in the burnt candles
and they pray before it and that's
idolatry do you see the distinction I'm
making there yes I do if there's a cross
in a building that doesn't mean that
that's an idol it may just be a logo
that it explains this is a Christian
Church or if you see a cross on a grave
typically you go through a military
cemetery and there was either a cross or
a Jewish star or the Muslim symbol there
on the grave and they're just identified
as a logo what their religion was that's
not an an idol but if someone's praying
before one of those things are
worshiping that or wanting to touch it
and think there's any virtue in it that
it's mystical let's hide Allah tree got
it thank you very much great question
next one that we have is a Herald
listening from Texas Herald welcome to
the program
hi possible I just want to know the
difference between a ceremonial and
ritual law well many of the ceremonial
laws are also ritual laws when you you
look at the laws basically there are
different laws that are outlined by
Moses as he's going through Exodus and
Leviticus mostly and he sometimes
mingles together the ceremonial ritual
laws the health laws and the civil laws
and I think I'm leaving some moral or
moral law Ten Commandments yeah what's
the difference between rituals and
ceremonial many of them are some of the
ceremony laws didn't have a ritual
connected with it right but there's
still ceremonial laws a lot of the the
laws connected with the sanctuary fell
into the category of both ceremonial as
well as ritual because it became sort of
the fabric and the culture of Israel so
it was something that was passed on from
family to family that was connected with
the sanctuary or with one of the feasts
that they were involved with if some of
the ceremonial laws were had to do with
cleanliness but that it was not
technically a ritual a ritual would be
one of the
is what you would call a ritual there's
a kind of a minor distinction there I
don't know if that helps a lot at all
Harold okay yeah a little bit okay you
know what we do have a book we can send
you that talks about does God's grace
blot out the law I've talked about the
ceremonial and the moral law and that
might be helpful we'll send you a free
copy of that all you'll need to do is
call and ask the book is simply called
does God's grace blot out the law and
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven and again just answer that book
called does God's grace blot out the law
next one of the we have is Stanford
listening from New York
Stanford welcome to the program thank
you thank you thank you um it's my first
time on the show and I must tell you
that I see you on the internet and I
know that the word is being preached
well thank you so much yes the world is
mcreech but my question is I've been
struggling with this and I do want to
understand I won't take much of your
time maybe a few minutes like three two
minutes um it said in Genesis chapter 49
and verse 8 I want to know Jacob is
blessing his son but when he came to
Judah
there was a special pronouncement upon
Judah and just to sum it up really quick
the part I want to understand is this
verse 10 it said 49 verse 10 it said the
scepter shall not depart from Judah nor
a lawgiver from between his feet until
Shiloh come and ensure be obedient of
the people so why was there a special
blessing upon Judah and not upon Babylon
or not yeah good question
you know when Jacob's blessing his sons
he goes farther and blessing Judah which
is interesting Judas not the firstborn
he's not the last born he's not even
born of Rachel the one the wife he loved
he's born of Leah I think he's the
fourth of Leah
but Judah is the one
whom Jesus would come that's why it says
a lawgiver the Kings were typically the
lawgivers Judah
David was from the tribe of Judah and
David had several of his ancestors that
ended up being Kings whereas the other
tribes of Israel they had several
different tribes that killed each other
off and you never knew who the next king
was going to be but the sons of David
stayed on the throne of judah the
southern kingdom for hundreds of years
ultimately Jesus came from the tribe of
Judah so and something else that's
interesting
Judah was the son or in our church were
going through the book of Genesis and
reading about Joseph Judah was the son
who wanted to sell Joseph as a slave but
then Judah was converted and he is the
son who later offers himself in Joseph's
place he says take me he becomes a
sacrifice to try to redeem Benjamin and
to offer himself Judah went through a
real a real change and it's interesting
right in the middle of the story of
Joseph it stops and starts talking about
Judah and his family tree not the other
tribes because Jesus would come through
the tribe of Judah so it's a great study
thank you hey thank you very much we
appreciate your question Sanford next
photo that we have these Becky listening
in Michigan Becky welcome to the program
hello pastor Doug and pastor Sean how
you doing good good and your question
tonight
I have a question impoverished chapter 3
24 to 26 it says when you lie down you
will not be afraid yes when you lie down
your sleep will be sweet do not be
afraid of sudden terror nor of the
trouble from the wicked when it comes
for the Lord will be your confidence and
he will keep your foot from being caught
now what's your question on those verses
what is the meaning of sometimes I do I
was marking my sometimes I marked my
Bible oh and I just come across a crime
across a long time ago and sometimes I
get nightmares I have bad dreams and I
get like nightmares at nighttime I just
I want to know from the Christian point
of view was the mean other
yeah well there's this is part of a
promise that God is making you'll notice
earlier in the chapter he's talking
about my son keep my commandments and
follow wisdom that's in verse 13 happy
as a man who finds wisdom the man who
gains understanding for her proceeds are
better than profits of silver and her
grain and fine gold so Solomon is saying
that if we have biblical wisdom and if
we obey God's commandments he gives us a
peace
the Bible calls it a peace that passes
understanding when Jesus is in our heart
he's called the Prince of Peace and it
can help you sleep more sweetly at night
you know usually somebody that is
worried or doing something illegal
pretty much it's hard for them to have
peace and rest and they worried looking
over their shoulder worrying about
somebody reporting something conscience
is bothering the conscience bothering
here it says those who are right with
God they can have peace doesn't mean
you'll never have a bad night or a bad
dream but it means there is a broader
peace that the followers of Christ have
that the world does not have so does
that help a little Becky
yes it did okay we hope you have that
peace thank you for your call
we've got Katherine listening from
Virginia Katherine
welcome to the program thank you I have
a question about the Book of Enoch I
have a young son that's 24 that has
recently read some of it and said he
felt like it shed some light we use you
know the King James Version and he wants
me you know to take a look at it I told
him that I would but I'm assuming that
there's a reason why it's not part of
the Bible do you know what that is
yep I mean I don't know anything about
you know I don't know anything about the
book I know it was supposedly you know
written by the prophet Enoch the seventh
from Adam yeah The Book of Enoch it's
very doubtful it was written by Enoch
the actual ancestor of Noah because
you'd have to think of all that book
some house survived the flood and Noah
kept it Noah passed it on and somehow it
survived Abraham's one
and the during the Babylonian captivity
there was somebody who wrote the Book of
Enoch and it became it's kind of like in
among English speakers we've got a
famous Christian book called pilgrims
progress you've heard of that right
right I have a great book full of
inspiration it's not part of the Bible
but it's got some great allegories in it
it's a let a lot of people to the Lord
well during the Babylonian captivity a
devout Jew wrote a book called The Book
of Enoch and every Jew knew it wasn't
written by Enoch but there was a
statement in there that I think it is it
Jude Jude quotes first yeah verse 14 it
says now this is Jude 1:14 Enoch the
seventh from Adam prophesied against
these men also saying behold the Lord
comes with ten thousand of his Saints to
execute judgment upon all so it's
referring to this passage that you find
in the Book of Enoch now it is possible
Katharine that Enoch uttered those words
and they were passed down orally just
like Moses got words that were passed
down orally from Adam and Eve and that
the Babylonian author was incorporating
that in his book see what I'm saying and
so James are Jude sorry quotes from that
so it's not anything it's not anything
out of it the Book of Enoch should be
included in the scriptures because
there's some other things in there
there's a little fishy okay if you're
looking at the books of the Bible were
assembled at least the Old Testament you
know they had to have a trustworthy
source and pretty much the Old Testament
was already established by the time of
Christ in the New Testament the criteria
for having your letter included in the
New Testament was he needed to be an
eyewitness of Jesus so the disciples the
only exception of that would be Paul but
Jesus did meet Paul on the road to
Emmaus or Damascus and then you also
needed to have a track record meaning
that the authorship of the letter was
agreed upon by multiple different
churches or church groups if there was
somebody who wrote a book and they said
I'm inspired and this book is needs to
be part of the New Testament and you
couldn't verify the authenticity
well that makes that makes perfect sense
I knew you know I felt like if the Lord
wanted it in there it would have been in
there but I basically was trying to find
out if it was anything bad you know that
you shouldn't read that's what I was
trying to find out but you explained it
yeah I don't think first some historical
interest it might be interesting but I
want to read it treating it any more
biblically than I would the pilgrims
progress or another you know
inspirational allegory right okay well
thank you then that's a lot of light on
it thank you very much
thanks so much appreciate your question
next quarter that we have is Monty
listening in Ohio Monty welcome to the
program
hello pastors how are you doing doing
great appreciate your call this is a
little deeper question maybe but it's on
typology you know in Corinthians 10 11 I
was there forty six nine to ten classes
one nine we typology is clearly endorsed
and I think you would agree that the
seventy weeks of Daniel 9:24 came to in
and thirty-four ad so it was the true
church leaders or the the leaders of the
true church at that time that demanded
the death of Christ on the cross
and I'm wondering uh in light of john
16:2 which says they will kill you
thinking they do got a service if you
think the history will repeat itself in
that fashion
will there be apostasy in the church
yeah well there's apostasy in the church
now I mean will but will there be
persecution from within yeah there yeah
do you think that the true leaders of
the leaders of the true church and I'm
just not going to identify that true
church obviously but we know that it's
that those that keep the commandments of
God had a testimony of Jesus
and you know and have the faith of Jesus
do you think that it will come to a
point because I know that the gates of
Hell will not prevail against God's
church but we are the building of God
according 23:9 so the people of God are
the true church not the organization so
do you think that it's a distinct
possibility that the true church and you
know who I'm talking about will be the
ones
/ yeah you know I know who you're
talking about I'm yeah we're wondering
do I think it's possible that loyal
Christians in leadership can persecute
believers within their own family it
happened the days of Jesus were the
disciples when they went to the temple
and I think history can repeat itself
matter of fact I think history is
repeated itself already many times
through history there are people who
find their way into leadership even in
Jesus among the Twelve Apostles
you've got Judas who is persecuting Mary
you know who wasted all this money so
you got someone who's technically in
Jesus leadership who's not converted
who's persecuting someone else in
Abraham's own family Hagar and Ishmael
were persecuting Isaac this family
friendly fire that's a friendly fire III
think it's gonna repeat itself in the
last days course people that are
persecuting people that get into a
church organization that may be genuine
you're gonna have true and false wheat
and tares everywhere and so ya know no
doubt be persecution some of our
greatest adversaries in the last days
will be those who once stood with us
deep within the pages of the Bible
stories of great heroes heroes of great
deeds great love
and great sacrifice but behind them is
another hero hidden in plain sight amid
the shadows he was there from the
beginning
and he'll be there until the end
discover the golden thread of a savior
woven throughout the entire bible
tapestry
shadows of light seeing Jesus in all the
Bible get your copy today by calling
855-578-6767
have him for cover sin did it go through
that yes absolutely you know it's God is
the one we sinned against ultimately and
he's the one who must forgive now if I
offend a brother or sister I go to them
and say will you forgive me
people cannot forgive our mortal sins
it's just God that can do that and
nowhere are we told to go to God through
a man we're to go to God through Christ
we can go directly before the throne
through
Jesus our mediator there is one mediator
between God and man Christ Jesus that's
not biblical to do that Thank You Linda
next hole that we have is Dwight
listening from
I think it's Alabama Dwight welcome to
the program yes thank you thanks for
taking my call
yeah my question is I've heard that in
1888 that was retinas by faith that
Jones and Waggoner that Christ could
have came then better thinking about the
wound had not been healed yet and other
processes yeah just after that a little
bit for our folks who might be wondering
1888 who's Jones and Waggoner well it's
interesting if you look at some of the
Protestant churches that grew out of the
early 1800s that culminated in what we
call the Mulla right movement in 1844
there were a series of messages or
truths that came to the world some of
the different individuals that God used
to bring that message of truth as you
mentioned Jones and Waggoner of course
we need to test
everybody's teaching by the Word of God
that is our ultimate test of all things
and then of course we do have prophecies
as you mentioned in the Bible which both
Revelation and Daniel speak of needing
to be fulfilled for example jesus said
in this gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached to all the world as a witness
unto all nations then the end will come
as some people did not fully understand
these prophecies or at least recognize
their importance as it fits into endtime
events and so yeah folks of a different
views or different perspectives on when
Jesus will come yeah there there are
some beliefs that you know Christ says
in Matthew 24:14 the gospel of the
kingdom will be preached in all the
world then the end will come and if
people had embraced righteousness by
faith the way it was preached during
this great revival in the 1880s some
have speculated that Jesus could have
come because the gospel would have gone
to the world of power yeah yeah but and
we're still waiting because gospel has a
long way to go in some countries who's
next pastor Ross we got a couple more
questions we can do a gene listening
from Wisconsin gene welcome to the
program hey good
even casters how are you doing tonight
great I have I have probably a real
simplistic speculative question here why
do you why do you believe that that God
works in the in the in a dimension
that's not visible as well as the angels
and of course the demons that are on the
planet Earth
why do you believe that he does not
allow us to see perhaps the angels
working or why can't we see that realm
you know that's a good question and I'm
glad you're asking it's not that
simplistic in the beginning I believe
man could see there's a whole nother
realm man had whatever spiritual
equipment he needed to be tuned into the
frequency of the spiritual realm after
sin something physically something
spiritually happened a man God could not
man could not see God in his glory and
he couldn't see the angels unless they
did something special to appear you know
we went along for over 5,000 years not
knowing about television waves or radio
waves or cosmic rays we know now that
there's all kinds of things happening in
and around us because we've just gained
knowledge I think when we get to heaven
we're gonna realize that there is a
perfectly scientific reason why people
could not see the spiritual realm in our
sinful condition we didn't have the
equipment you know now we're surrounded
by devices that are picking up invisible
messages you think about how much more
we're gonna know in a thousand years you
know once we thought that you know are
the whole universe is just the Sun and
the moon and now we know there's the
whole solar system with planets an old
galaxy and our Milky Way galaxy is one
galaxy of 200 billion suns and it goes
on and on from there I heard a TED talk
this week that they think there are
other universes that ours is just one
universe filtery and that's it just goes
on and on so there's so much we don't
know and I think that's why you know
just after that if let's just say angel
did appear and they are cases you read
about in the Bible and even some
testimony of people even today where
they feel as though an angel did appear
to them and bring them a message but
even if our eyes were open and we could
see the unseen the angels
both couldn't bet I don't think it'll
make that much of a difference in
convicting someone of the need for a
savior give an example when Jesus was on
the earth he performed some incredible
miracles and yet it still didn't
convince the religious leaders to turn
to Christ
even the resurrecting of Lazarus from
the dead they still refused so if there
was some miracle that God could perform
to get everyone's attention probably do
that but would it result in people
genuinely being converted probably not
it has to be the moving of the holy
spirit and it needs to be faith without
faith it's impossible to please God
absolutely I don't know if it helps at
all Jeanne yep you did yes actually you
answered it fairly fairly quickly and
and very thoroughly so I appreciate that
Patras you two have a great evening
all right thanks so much for your call
what do you think pastor Ross can we do
one quick question and yes let's try it
we got Donny in Chattanooga Tennessee we
have about a minute Donna well my
question is very simple
I've always wondered what it means by
giving marriage and giving in marriage
of course I know what marriage is but
giving in marriage what does that mean
you know pastor Ross and I performed
several weddings and sometimes just at
the beginning of the actual ceremony the
bride walks in and she stands next to
her father in some cases her mother and
you say who gives this woman to this man
because and that's an ancient tradition
it used to be families were saying we
support this Union and the parents
basically and the bride would kiss her
father after that and basically he's
saying you know I've been your protector
and now your husband is your protector
and that's where that terminology kind
of comes from it's a beautiful but it's
a sort of ancient custom parents used to
arrange all these marriages like Abraham
did for Isaac it's like who gives this
man to this woman who gives this woman
to this man so Jordan okay okay it just
never made sense to me and I thought you
know marriage and giving in marriage I
figured they were the same thing
marriage and arrangement of mayor
urges when they say someone was given in
marriage okay well thank you you
answered my question I can go to sleep
now did you sleep peacefully Thank You
Donna
they tell us for everywhere we go we
help people fall asleep hey listening
friends go to our website amazing facts
dot o-r-g
we'll talk next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth calm what if
you could know the future
what would you do what would you change
to see the future you must understand
the past Alexander the Great becomes
king when he's only 18 but he's a
military prodigy a hundred and fifty
years in advance Cyrus had been named
Rahm was violent they were ruthless
they were determined the Gospel writers
seek his death as a fulfillment of
salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com journey back
through time to the center of the
universe discover how a perfect angel
transformed into satan the arch villain
the birth of evil a rebellion in heaven
a
that move - it
behold the creation of a beautiful new
planet and the first humans witness the
temptation of evil
discover God's amazing plan to save his
children this is a story that involves
every life on Earth every life
the cosmic conflict if God is good if
God is all-powerful if God is love then
what went wrong
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF Axio RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word
to take advantage of the offers you've
heard on this broadcast
call us at $887 may seem facts 0 RG
[Music]